I was going to talk about a thing called
the brunt device Salah frequency well
first thing to say about it is one of
the reason why I wanted to talk about it
is he actually has a symbol so getting
back to sixty symbols roots for some
reason this particular frequency is
always given the symbol capital N and
actually I've tried very hard to find
out why it's called capital N and I
can't find anyone who would explain why
it's called capital n it's just every
textbook you find it in it's always
called capital in you'll find out in the
comments probably here all right what
actually is it so actually what got me
to thinking about this is just the other
day I was thinking I knew you were
coming to do some filming I think what
can I talk about and I was just glancing
up at the sky and it was one of those
days where the clouds were in lines you
know you sometimes see very neatly
arrayed lines of clouds and I realized
that actually there's a really nice
simple piece of physics which explain
why you sometimes get the clouds in
lines like that you find it particularly
if there's a mountain downstream from
the mountain if you got air blowing over
the mountain you'll find these lines of
clouds there so what's actually
happening is so on we need to back up a
little bit and do a little bit of
physics which is I need to talk about
buoyancy so I forgot a balloon a helium
filled balloon and of course it rises
because it's less dense than the air
around it and obviously the less dense
something is the faster it rises and
obviously if it's bent at than air it'll
sink and if you've got to be exactly
right it's exactly the same average
density is the air around it'll just
float wherever you put it and if you
move your head up it'll stay there and
if you move it down it'll stay there so
that's the thing called neutral buoyancy
that the thing just basically stays
wherever you put it and that that's what
will happen if you've got kind of a
uniform density atmosphere that you can
take something if it's floating there
you move it up it's still floating if on
the other hand you've got a stratified
atmosphere so actually it's very the
density decreases as you go up as the
Earth's atmosphere does then what'll
happen is you've got something which is
neutrally buoyant at this point and
let's get rid of the balloon let's just
have a little blob of air there if you
were to displace it upwards suddenly
it's surrounded by air that's less dense
than it is and so it'll sink again and
it'll keep sinking it'll actually sink
through its own original point and then
it'll find itself in a region where it's
less dense than the stuff around it and
now it'll start to rise and so it will
actually oscillate backwards and
forwards and the frequency at which it
oscillates backwards and forwards is
this thing called the brunt Vaisala
frequency and the reason why that has to
do with these lines of clouds is that if
you have
some air with some moisture in it if it
starts undergoing these oscillations
then as it rises it'll cool and suddenly
it'll cool to the point where clouds
condense and so you actually make clouds
and then when it sinks again those
clouds will then evaporate again and the
clouds will disappear so if you've got
air which is traveling along and
undergoing these oscillations
you'll get clouds then the clouds will
disappear then the clouds will appear
again then the clouds will disappear
again in the atmosphere the period of
this oscillation is something it's of
order a hundred seconds typically if you
look at the the atmosphere is stratified
and use all the physical parameters it
works out about 100 seconds and
typically air is traveling at maybe 10
meters per second normal kind of wind
speed so in each oscillation it will
have traveled about a 10 meters per
second over 100 seconds you travel a
kilometer and that's why the scale of
these clouds is typically a kilometer or
so that you'll get a cloud then a gap
then a cloud and this typical spacing
between them is the border a kilometer
it's actually well they're the same air
we're here in the cloud and then the
cloud will disappear again
so you basically create the cloud and
then the cloud disappears in the cloud
appear so you're sort sort of seeing
those high peaks when it goes up it
forms the cloud and it's wherever you're
at the top you'll get the cloud and then
it disappears again and then reappears
again white that also lets you fade away
when it eventually stopped oscillating
and just sort of stopped like like a
like a pendulum eventually runs out of
pop if you just look at the maths you
actually even figure out what the mass
of this oscillation is it really is to
think this thing called the harmonic
oscillator and the harmonic oscillator
will just keep oscillating forever now
obviously there are other effects going
on as well so there are will be damping
terms which means that actually one of
these waves won't actually loss forever
but it really can persist for many many
oscillations so actually you can have
these whole series of clouds being
created in that way so this frequency
comes up all over the place so it comes
up in oceans because you can exactly the
same effects in oceans of pockets of
water rising and falling in stars you
can have little bits of the star in the
stellar atmosphere rising and falling
and they're all driven by this same
frequency of this pranic Vaisala
frequency
he's at the other side of the solar
system and again something here again
you can see the net pull of the earth
and the Sun is all nicely lined up which
will keep it in an orbit basically
following following the earth around
there used to be lots of science fiction
stories about l-3 used to be a popular
place to put the anti earth or you know
if you're an evil genius that's where
you put your hidden layer